[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 les invités une
émission dédiée à celles et à ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département est
aujourd'hui mercredi à 19 avril parole à
véronique chaplin responsable de la
journée tiebreak une journée organisée
depuis 25 ans dans les yvelines et qui
associe sport et solidarité au profit de
l'association sos gazelle chaque année
de nombreux sportifs et champions
participent à l'événement pour la bonne
cause nous évoquerons le sujet avec elle
mon début de cette émission avec de la
politique à quatre jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
les réunions publiques se multiplient
c'était le cas il ya quelques jours à
trappes dans le fief électoral du
socialiste benoît hamon une soirée
dédiée à l'économie sociale et solidaire
était organisée par le mouvement en
marche des manuels macro christophe
istya spécialiste de cette thématique
pour l'ancien ministre de l'économie
était au micro de nicolas d'andry
écoutez le à l'époque de la loi avait 16
c'était j'étais membre du mouvement des
entrepreneurs sociaux qui a contribué
très fortement à l'élaboration de la loi
donc on a travaillé avec le cabinet de
benoît hamon à 7 sur cette loi et c'est
une bonne loi
c'est une loi qui a pour la première
fois posé les le périmètre du périmètre
du secteur qui a défini des critères de
gouvernance d'objets évidemment sociales
ou environnementales également des
critères d'échelle d'échelle de salaires
donc ce qui fait le modèle vertueux de
le ss et puis clarifier ensemble de
dispositions notamment sur le la
question de la subvention et de l'accès
aussi la finance à la finance solidaire
or vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
meilleur accès aux financements pour les
acteurs de l'ess plus de pouvoir
d'action pour les salariés qu'est-ce-qui
emmanuel macron souhaite ajouter à cette
loi de du 31 juillet dollar et or
d'abord tout ne passe pas par la loi
premièrement la loi va poser un cadre
maintenant il faut la faire vivre
c'était une bonne chose maintenant on
est vraiment dans le développement de le
ss et donc il ya deux choses qui sont
déjà dans les fondamentaux du projet d'e
mails macron c'est libérer l'énergie des
acteurs de l'ess est ce donc c'est par
exemple tous les acteurs de l'eau et
c'est ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui transformées l'allègement de
le crédit d'impôt recherche
le candidat poupart dont le cic eux de
le transformer en allègements de charges
pérennes pour toutes les entreprises de
la ss pour m'en libérer les énergies
c'est toute une série dispositions
d'accès à la commande publique aussi
facilité pour les acteurs de la ss pour
les aider à être beaucoup plus autonomes
et beaucoup plus performants dans leur
gestion et leur développement et puis
par ailleurs deuxième enjeu très fort
deux des acteurs de l'ess et
d'innovation sociale commandant ce temps
qu'on que l'on connaît d'une économie
contraintes notamment sur les dépenses
publiques si on libère les énergies
c'est aussi comment on est meilleur en
termes de financement de l'innovation ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire concentrer
ainsi nombre de fonds qui existe déjà
faire une agrégation des fonds pour
développer l'innovation de ces données
un droit d expérimentation s'est
déverrouillé ensemble de normes ou
d'argumentation qui en ferait
l'innovation des acteurs de l'ess et 3c
ouvrira données publiques pour permettre
aux acteurs de la ss d'évaluer l'impact
social environnemental et sociétal de
leurs actions alors on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de pauvres en france il ne
cesse d'augmenter les inégalités ne
cessent d'augmenter aussi est-ce que le
ss c'est un point de sortie justement
pour lutter contre l'inégalité et contre
la pauvreté
alors évidemment et là je vous parle en
tant que aussi dirigeant d'une
association médico-social qui justement
travaillent sur ces questions de lutte
contre les exclusions contre la pauvreté
mais il n'ya pas que il ya effectivement
un accompagnement à renforcer des
associations pour sortir les gens de la
rue les remettre les aider à retrouver
un travail un logement
et toute la politique du logement
d'abord aussi qui développe et d'un
problème dé même lac rond et puis après
derrière il ya aussi la question du
recours aux allocations puisque souvent
dans certains discours on n'entend
qu'eux
il ya des dérives qu'il ya des fraudes
sociales mais là aussi il faut le savoir
par exemple sur le rsa à 30% des gens
qui pourraient avoir accès à ces assauts
rsa qui ne l'ont pas n'ont pas accès ne
font pas la démarche pour diverses
raisons complexité administrative ou
simplement ne pas avoir envie d'être
étiqueté bénéficier du rsa et donc on a
un problème de recours est ce que
proposait macron c'est de regrouper
l'ensemble des allocations apl rsa est
pris est pris une activité d'en faire un
recours systématique pour éviter
justement qui n'est ni égalité et qu'on
entre les gens dans l'exclusion à
maurepas à cette fois ci les partisans
locaux de jean luc mélenchon étaient
réunis eux pour parler des quartiers
populaires parce qu'à 3 déc responsable
de ce volet pour le fondateur du front
de gauche étaient notamment présents
quand on pense à un problème on a envie
de l'éviter leur temps qu'on considérera
que les quartiers populaires santé un
problème on cherchera à éviter de
regarder ce qui s'y passe
or les quartiers populaires c'est avant
tout une grande richesse ni richesse
démographique une richesse culturelle
artistique une richesse sportive
économique et même une refaire une
richesse civique puisqu'aujourd'hui la
lutte contre les discriminations elle
s'exerce essentiellement à partir des
classes populaires
alors pour développer cette richesse
voulait notamment mettre l'accent sur
l'éducation c'est la priorité je me dire
de votre volet pour les quartiers
populaires qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire concrètement pour l'éducation pour
les quartiers populaires déjà on va
établir un certain nombre de principes
par exemple celui qui consiste à dire
que l'école n'est pas là pour apprendre
un métier à l'école c'est un outil qui
sert à forger le citoyen de demain dans
la recherche de son autonomie et à
forger le citoyen dans certains domaines
émancipateur à partir de là lorsque
lorsqu'on pense l'éducation de cette
manière là on la traite bien évidemment
en matière de l'école nous la doit aussi
à l'extérieur de l'école avec la
tradition de l'éducation populaire qui
peut tout aussi bien intégrer l'ensemble
des membres d'une communauté éducative
que peuvent être les enseignants les
parents les usagers les enfants les
élèves même les associations les
institutions locales on voit là on
s'inscrit nous dans cette logique et sa
globalité une éducation populaire tifo
et citoyens de demain
sur le volet du chômage maintenant
qu'ils ont c'est plus important dans les
quartiers populaires comment vous voulez
lutter contre ce fléau qui touche les
quartiers populaires depuis maintenant
de nombreuses années et plusieurs
aspects il ya ce qui a trait à la sphère
marchande strictement donc la première
chose c'est bien évidemment de combattre
et de condamner les employeurs qui mène
une discrimination par rapport au lieu
d'origine des salariés donc là c'est
tout l'aspect qui va consister à un
conte dernier lorsqu'on constate une
discrimination à lutter contre les
factures de ces discriminations par
exemple avec la mise en oeuvre du cv
anonyme
ça c'est pour la gigja la sphère
marchande mais au delà de la sphère
marchande il faut repenser la question
du travail d'une manière plus globale
également et intégrer l'ensemble des
emplois et l'ensemble de la richesse que
représentent les emplois d'intérêt
collectif ce que l'on appelle les jeunes
comme les emplois de solidaires voilà
pour faire simple une question sur une
réflexion sur le vote des quartiers
populaires on sait qu' il ya une
tendance ces dernières années à voter
plutôt nationale est ce que c'est ce
vote là qu'il faut récupérer par exemple
pour jean luc mélenchon totalement pour
espérer franchir ce ce palier ce plafond
de verre des 20% et puis accéder au
second tour puis à la présidence de la
république
il ya deux choses à ce que vous décrivez
on peut entendre qu'un certain nombre de
personnes désespérées ou vraiment devenu
hostile à la manière dont la classe
politique les considère puisse aller aux
extrêmes
en ce qui nous concerne nous on va
plutôt travailler sur un travail
d'éducation la politique là travaillent
donc pédagogique et avec pour objectif
d'aller s'intéresser s'adresser aux
abstentionnistes qui sont extrêmement
nombreux dans les quartiers pour les
rétablir dans leurs droits civiques
merci parce que 3d merci à vous et on
poursuit cette émission avec notre
invité plateau véronique chaplin bonsoir
vous est la fondatrice et responsable de
la journée tiebreak une journée qui
associe sport et solidarité depuis 25
ans et votre 25e anniversaire au profit
de l'association sos gazelle la
prochaine journée tiebreak c'est le 23
mai au golf de bêtes - est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler c'est de cette
journée nous peut dire de quoi il s'agit
on aura c'est ça des champions des
jeunes et puis des activités sportives
tout à fait en fait ils journée très
conviviale qui réunit depuis 25 ans sur
un golf des sportifs de haut niveau de
disciplines variées très différentes et
on a toujours la chance d'avoir une
cinquantaine de personnalités de tous
bords des médaillés olympiques des
champions du monde et champions d'europe
ils sont tous là certes pour se
rencontrer et faire une compétition
amicale de golf qui lie à roland garros
et avec quand même un titre à la clé
parce que c'était leur encontre des
champions c'est ça ou voilà le titre de
champion des champions marine de
champion mais en réalité sont des grands
champions au grand coeur parce qu'ils
viennent tous pour la cause des enfants
au profit 100 % de l'association sos
gazelles qui fonctionne qu'avec des
bénévoles et donc ces sportifs viennent
totalement bénévolement le jour j
encadre des jeunes puisque à côté de la
compétition de golf on est on a une
dizaine d'ateliers multisports on peut
se faire par exemple de la boxe sur quoi
on peut s'initier à la boxe
oui mais ce qu'on ne rate on aura trois
champions du monde de boxe en d3 à
l'aplomb du monde de boxe via toujours à
ne va pas présenter qui est très très
appréciée on a un nouvel atelier aussi
cfoot golf cette année du fou de golf du
foot golfe toujours de l'athlétisme du
badminton du rugby y en a pour tous les
goûts
une journée sportive pour là pour la
bonne cause c'est facile de motiver ses
champions pour ce genre de journée ils
viennent facilement oularé chaque année
vous avez beaucoup de mon action et non
impressionnant j'ai la chance d'avoir
beaucoup de monde mais
parce que c'est un travail de longue
haleine moi j'ai toujours travaillé dans
le milieu du sport et autres ces
journées tiebreak on fait des choses
ensemble dont qui sont très mobilisés
ils sont venus aussi il ya six mois au
sénégal
ils ont été jusque là pas parce qu'ils
savent que c'est 100 % pour les jeunes
ils ont un emploi du temps hyper chargé
je prends l'exemple de gomis qui était
d'accord pour être parent il sera par un
sa présence est encore en suspens donc
gomis le joueur de l'olympique de
marseille exactement d'origine
sénégalaise alors cette année vous avez
notamment des jeunes qui viennent de
trappes qui vont participer à cette
journée mais pas que est-ce que vous
pouvez aussi nous donner peut-être des
noms un peu ronflant qui sont sur eux
participé à cette 25e journée tiebreak
alors on a nos fidèles comme antoine
kambouaré comme laurent blanc comme
yannick noah on a aussi pas mal de
personnalités du spectacle
bruno solo jean luc reichmann arnaud
gidoin l'acteur le comédien stéphane
freiss philippe lavil et puis on a aussi
des grands champions dans toutes les
disciplines les anciens du psg on en a
pas mal
il ya un vrai lien entre états unis on
vient forcément ça doit faciliter les
choses active en piste sont devenus des
amis parce qu'on travaille depuis
longtemps avec votre 25e anniversaire on
le répète un mot peut-être sur aussi sos
gazelle l'association pierre en fait le
tiebreak et effets uniques exclusivement
pour ça on va financer grâce au tiebreak
c'est à dire aux entreprises qui
viennent le jour j et la vente aux
enchères caritative d'objets mythique de
champion ouverte à tout le monde on le
précise voilà ouvert de lab recherche
le soir de 19 voix là donc c'est
l'occasion de passer une fois avec les
sportifs puis d'accéder éventuellement
un maillot du psg dédicacé par vera ti
une raquette aussi deux chambres louées
je suis des maillots de l'om pour les
maillots de rugby sérieux glisse wii est
en fait ensuite les dons sont reversés à
l'association sos gagne toile à 100 %
des dons avec trois axes cette année des
enfants autistes
le silence des justes
sans sport éducation et santé à saly
joseph avec notre chèr chef de village
thomas avec qui on collabore depuis 11
ans et surtout un nouveau programme pour
les jeunes d'ile-de-france et les jeunes
des yvelines qui le programme sport et à
laon où nous allons prendre en charge à
360° avec la prévention santé des
conseils alimentaires du coaching mental
et un parent champion des jeunes qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'aller en fait des
ou en sport études
donc ça c'est vraiment le le vrai plus
de cette année tous ces jeunes qui sont
près de nous et qui pourront donc ce
sont pour les jeunes d'ici d'ailleurs
donc c'est une vraie bonne cause on
rappelle peut-être la date c'est le même
arbre avait pas rocher prochain excusez
moi au golden rice mort voilà au golf du
vêtement et puis si on veut plus
d'informations on peut je crois taper
sos gazelle sur internet sur la
discipline à des informations et
notamment pour la vôtre la vente aux
enchères du voila voila je fais un appel
à tous les gens qui ont envie de faire
une action à la fois utile et conviviale
et sympathique mais ressasser une
journée avec no mercy
véronique est revenue en plateau puis
donc bon courage pour pour
l'organisation encore j'imagine de cette
journée tiebreak le 23 mai prochain en
golf 2 bêtement c'est la fin de ce set 8
les invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain d'ici là tous nos reportages
à retrouver sur tv fil 78 points comme
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]